I need to start this video off on a sad note.
On New Year's Day, I lost my father unexpectedly at the age of 57.
He lived a good full life, but I just want to remind everybody to enjoy the time you have
with your family because it can end before you know it.
I'd like to say thank you to everybody who supports this project, and I look forward to
bringing you a whole bunch of awesome resources in 2018.
To kick things off, I'm going to give you a quick, angular productivity booster to eliminate
long relative paths that look like this to a single global namespace.
This means you can give all of your feature modules a specific namespace, and you never
really have to worry about relative paths within your project.
To demonstrate this, I'm starting off in a brand new Angular 5 app, and I'm going to generate
a couple of ng modules, first one being core, second one being shared.
From there I'm going to generate a service inside of the core module, we'll just go ahead
and call this the off service.
And I'm going to generate a component, but for no reason at all I'm going to nest this
deeply within the file structure of the project.
Let's go ahead and call it the deeply nested user login component.
Then if we look at the file structure on the left, you can see the actual component file
itself is nested about six levels deep within our project.
This isn't really a problem, unless we need to import this file in a different file that's
nested higher up.
So let's try this by importing the service into the component.
Just a quick side tip here, whenever you...